he dragged me and said nothing wow
they're going in-depth I don't think
that teams know more about social media
that idea my god
hi I'm Victoria Elizabeth oh I'm ready
today we are going to be roasting some
buzz feeders instagrams
I don't know I'm nervous about this it's
good
kids say exactly what baby is on their
minds I'll say what you want to bei give
me tips bless me I like it
first impressions I did a drag video and
I was supposed to glue down my eyebrows
that is not my normal look okay there
could be a feed she see she up he's like
the first two pictures she has are like
they have blue in it so like she could
start a blue fee so she's posting about
that she's also posting about things
outside of like work but she seems very
confident she posts regularly like oh
boy
they said I post so much doesn't lie cuz
I think the last time I post it was like
two weeks ago okay so I used to be told
that I have to post once every day so
now I post like once I'd be like three
days but posting twice in one day is
ridiculous
I say about once a week don't do it so
much where it's like tiny little dots
this was refreshing cuz I was really
afraid that they were gonna go in there
and be like yes pink shirt and my
picture young man picture but they liked
it apparently I need to start like a
blue theme I'm down for it yeah they're
looking at mine I was not nervous
actually seems pretty hilarious I only
got a song on but it's like funny I feel
like if she's just like a very comedic
so did he move this couch into the
street or you did you see him random cow
Moo this Trina say let me flick up on
his couch I didn't I did not move that
couch into my street it was there which
is embarrassing because and now I
realized from an outsider's perspective
that it probably looks like I was it
absorbed in him out of it at first what
I did I mean am i but like I didn't do
and so I see that he works for BuzzFeed
he's going to post a picture of him
dancing this is drink responsibly rose
day all day
so is he drinking on the job oh wow I
like his I like his aesthetic though for
Instagram
he has a good ratio followers to follow
me it looks better if you're following
less like a lot less people than P
wonderfully good team's thing my name is
cool that's fun I guess I don't know
that cool god I'm just I'm laying I'm
not that I'm I'm gonna go but first
impressions she seems very silly and
like really good to hang out with she
post a lot a lot of goofy pictures I saw
the Yoshi stucked care corn up her nose
and carrot corns nasty do you eat candy
corn
oh yeah candy corn care cause I'm sure
she has a highlight called bugs of bugs
in her house oh oh that's so scary oh my
gosh wait yeah and she puts soap in her
twin so I don't know what she needs a
plumber exterminator she needs a lot of
things
she put her feet on the wiki feed I did
not put my feet on wiki feet I just want
to make that clear I wound up on wiki
feet and that's the whole story I just
think she's pretty funny I'm not gonna
say like post more serious pictures was
that not that's not who she is
I'm still scrolling and doesn't stop the
quality has gotten better the scrolling
still doesn't stop well maybe it's
because she's had she's had it for a
long time but she doesn't pose every day
she's had her proboscis 2011
just clean it up a little be not delete
some metal pics um I think they mailed
that I'm silly I disagree that he thinks
I pose too much it's my personal content
creator strategy and I'm sticking by it
I'm standing by it I'm just gonna keep
doing I'm doing this is fun no thanks
for your thoughts
kids I'm kind of nervous because my
Instagram is like not meant for teens I
feel like oh and they're judging you'll
see her whole Instagram is like the
whole is like her eating this is a huge
taco Oh
oh my gosh what the heck see like
Instagram oh yes real cool person yeah
really cool kind of like really fun to
hang out with yeah because she doesn't
care about how she looks in his post on
her vine yeah she's like very
non-judgmental where he's all right I
really don't care about how I look I
just make it about the food they get me
some better food choices I see a lot I
don't see too many vegetables here I
mean just likes what's about it yeah
food is like nasty sometimes and like
trashy and like that's me so I want to
portray food as it is in my world
to expect your thoughts strange mustache
haha very first five rows of posts no
because I don't know it's just cut I
mean I guess I'd like she'd like a look
at like the captions but they're kind of
like meaningless you had this whole
thing like right here this whole section
words like really aesthetic and then egg
went away that's true I had like a solid
aesthetic going and I kind of just
messed it all up
he said I went and got myself stuck
another picture folks please sing butter
and a spare key hashtag healthy like the
pictures could be better like he's fun
to be around with though yeah have a
good time yeah
oh my gosh oh there's this highly
Colombian rumba and at the very last
part this this story that says OMG you
guys call the cops somebody you got a
lot of explaining to do
rumba rumba what is that a night a lot
of free time it was I mostly got roasted
which is fine I was kind of expecting
that my Instagram is a bit all over the
place and maybe this is a bit of
inspiration kicking the pants to get me
back on my Instagram try to impress the
teens that's the goal no take a joke I
got coming back son
okay so he's their father very good
he's a funny dude that little video
talking about my weed beer but it looks
like he travels he takes good quality
pictures he's theirs I've always been
the same like feed aesthetic thing and
like looks the same if you want to
follow how to set up a profile look at
this man right here never go around for
verification the blue shake he post a
little bit too much stuff lately also is
promoting his business yes I am pretty
cool yeah they know what I'm doing
you know the understand the business
side of it you can relay the message on
to the person but don't keep on sinning
and keep on posting a delete post delete
post because people's gonna get
irritated he post things but he doesn't
post anything wild post everything that
it really stands out to me is a no-no
everything seems pretty cool yeah
they've been too nice maybe we are come
on
yeah break out the guns y'all at least
say yo mama joke
remember those the candy corn I can't
no candy corn please now that I've just
gone and dissected people's instagrams I
realized how I want my Instagram to me
more people understand who you are when
they look at your Instagram
[Music]
you
[Music]